رضاه بات مطلوبه من الطرفين اي اردوغان
وكليتشار اوغلو بعد حصله 5% من اصوات
الاتراك في الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه سنان اوغن يوصف بصانع
الملوك او بيضه القبان في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه مع قدره اصوات انصاره على قلب
المعادله اوغان الذي حل ثالثا بالدوره
الاولى اكد انه منفتح على الحوار مع كلا
المرشحين لكنه المح حائل امكانيه دعوه
انصاره وناخبيه لدعم اردوغان لكنه كرر
مواقفه فيما يخص القضيه الكرديه فشدد على
معارضه كل منظمه بنفسها عن الارهاب اي في
اشاره لحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الداعم
هنا يقف كليتشار اوغلو امام خيارين كلاهما
ليس في مصلحته خساره اصوات اوغان او خساره
التصويت الكردي خياران اذا احلاهما مر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات